I knew John Chambers very well and
Verner I knew a lot of the makeup guys
Danny Street back I mean I used to hang
out on the Planet of the Apes stuff and
so I was really into that stuff and I
tried to get people to make the original
conception for schlock was a bad gorilla
suit I went at one point I was Don post
Studios in Burbank they made those
pullover a rubber mask they used to sell
on Hollywood Boulevard and they he
wanted like $100,000 or something and I
had the budget was 60 so it's like no
but as I was leaving Don post junior who
was painting a mask said to me can I get
him over and he said there was a kid in
here who's really talented and gave me
the card
that's a Rick Baker monster maker and it
had his mother's phone number and I okay
just on post Jr you must know something
so I call them and come out so we drove
out to his parents house parents Rick
had spectacular parents anyway drove out
to the house which was a total lower
like a blue-collar neighborhood you know
and we go out there and we go into Rick
you know Rick is this kid with bad skin
and very long hair and very shy I heard
later you were absolutely terrified by
me
because I used the f-word you know and I
but we we went back into his bedroom he
was an only child his father's a good
fine painter and encouraged trick
interest in makeup and on in his room
you know like a lot of kids he had you
know masks and models and and things he
had done now I've been around
professional movies now for four or five
you know yeah five years you know and
I'd work them and I never forget it I
thought Gemma sighs I said this kid is
really good I mean the work was
extraordinary
and he made all the molds for schlock in
his mom's oven and she complained for
years that her pies smelled like foam
rubber but anyway I gave him the script
of American Werewolf then you know we
both were big fans of The Wolfman and
Jekyll and Hyde you know in in in
transformations on screen but John said
you know it just didn't make sense to
him that you would sit in a chair and be
still until you changed into into a
werewolf and and he wanted to show the
pain and in London they used to have
cartoon cinemas which were small
theaters that showed cartoons and
newsreels and commercials and parents
would if they were shopping on the high
street they would drop their kids off
there so there'd be like homeless guys
out of the cold and children watching
these cartoons and when I worked in
London I would go to the cartoon cinemas
the arrow cinnamon Piccadilly which is
in the movie and stuff because they
showed this is before home you have to
remember before home video before this
stuff was accessible but they would show
gorgeous prints of Chuck Jones and you
know Bob Clampett and Tex Avery cartoons
so I would go see these I remember that
Bond folks all thought I was nuts but
I'd go see them and so when I wrote you
know the in the script with the first
eye it's a cartoon he's seeing a
roadrunner cartoon and it's children and
in many ways is kind of creepier but so
in 1981 by the time week I got you know
gonna get to me I go back to London and
no more cartoon cinemas and the only
ones left word
porno theaters so that's the only
difference
he changed my life in so many ways I
mean it'll probably say in my tombstone
hey this is a guy did American we're in
London make up no and because of John I
got thriller and coming to America and
and a Nutty Professor and and all these
movies that have been so important in my
life and it's also because of John Ashe
he met my wife and I have these two
beautiful daughters I mean what he did
was not the father of my daughters but
but but that's how that's so I mean
John's very special in my life actually
what's very cool is Rick's wife Sylvia
was a hairdresser on a movie I made
called into the night and she wanted to
she said you know she want I always off
tinfoil in the movies actors and I had
Rick made a drug dealer we were on
Hollywood Boulevard
he's a scene with Michelle Pfeiffer and
Jeff Goldblum where Rick tries to see
he's very good and he's trying to sell
him some drugs and I needed some hookers
so I said the hairdresser I go Sylvia
you be a hooker so I have this wonderful
photograph of this real sleazy drug
dealer this hooker on Hollywood
Boulevard that's how they met